what's up guys mass nintendo bandit here
so the age of calamity trailer dropped
out of nowhere last week and if you
don't know what i'm talking about
first off stop living under a rock and
come out into the light because this is
all
anyone in the zelda community is talking
about these days the prequel to breath
of the wild that nobody even knew was
coming in the first place
now something to note is that this isn't
a legend of zelda title
it's actually a hyrule warriors title
which for those of you in the know
means that it will play kind of
differently than the original breath of
the wild
actually very differently you see
warriors games are much more hack and
slash oriented in an arcade style of
gameplay
where the main focus besides the story
is to get the biggest combo and smash
the most enemies with your final move
but the cool thing about age of calamity
as opposed to the first hyrule warriors
is that it's not a new world and story
that can be dismissed entirely it is
legitimately the events that transpired
a hundred years ago before breath of the
wild
the events before the re-emergence of
calamity gannon that are alluded to all
throughout the game
but because it is a hyrule warriors game
i have
certain expectations or hopes for it
that i figured i'd share with you guys
oh and if you're watching this on or
near the day that i went live with this
video
i'm probably on vacation right now so be
sure to smash that subscribe button if
you enjoy the video so that i can meet
you when i get back
and now without further ado here are the
five biggest expectations i have for age
of calamity
in age of calamity we're gonna need
answers lots of answers
mainly focusing on our main characters
like how the champions really died or
how link obtained the master sword
initially
or even just what life was like when
hyrule castletown wasn't
you know burned to the ground and the
trailer even brought up more
questions like an apparent assault of
gerudo town from the yiga clan
or the existence of potentially more
than one sheikah slate
but more than this we need and i stress
this very fervently
we need these answers to be confirmed as
canon
because even though this game was
directly requested to be made from mr
aonuma himself
and even though it takes place in the
same universe with the same characters
as the original game
there are still people out there who
will either debate the canon of this
game or who will use this game's canon
status to reflect upon the original
hyrule warriors
nintendo has stated that the first game
was not canon
so i think they need to similarly state
that this one is
it just has to happen it can't be left
up to debate a good way to do this would
be to slot it in behind breath of the
wild on the timeline
that would clear up any confusion over
whether or not its events are actually
canon and would also solidify its place
as the first
non-legend of zelda title in the zelda
timeline secondly
i want to see some variation to the
warriors hack and slash kind of gameplay
don't get me wrong
it's fun it's a lot of fun actually
especially when you mix in a whole bunch
of different characters with different
movesets and weapons
but choosing one of the many overpowered
characters and spamming the attack
button four times in a row over and over
until you can smash the final move and
then rinse and repeat until the
battleground is cleared gets
kind of old after a while if it did
release and had the same
intermission clear enemies repeat style
of gameplay i'd be
okay but would honestly only play it for
the story at that point and would
probably not keep it up afterwards
but if they introduced other objectives
like maybe collectibles or exploration
or good old-fashioned zelda puzzles
that would be much more likely to keep
people playing the game for longer and
speaking of varied gameplay
i'd like to see some varied missions in
the game one would think that since this
game will be covering the absolute loss
to calamity ganon years ago there might
be some missions that include not
obliterating every enemy on the
battlefield but
rather maybe trying to evacuate
civilians from neighboring towns
or maybe even towards the end of the
game getting a mission that plays
through link's final moments before
entering his slumber for a hundred years
that entailed having to run away with
zelda now that
would be cool and i know it would also
be completely out of the ordinary for a
warriors game but if we could get a few
missions as the champions becoming the
champions and having to maybe go through
not enemies but
trials to prove themselves again that
would be cool and would serve to mix up
the kinds of missions that you have to
embark on to keep players enthusiastic
about pressing that start button
because as you know warriors games are
not generally open world
they're mission based and are launched
from a menu screen but
speaking of the menu screen fourthly i'd
like to see instead of launching from a
menu
maybe a hub world that you can launch
into missions from
this would serve to immerse players into
the world of pre-calamity hyrule better
than ever before
just imagine if you're going through
lynx missions and your hub world is
hyrule castle not only can you explore
the castle but you could walk over to
zelda to enter a research mission or to
the king to enter a battleground mission
or maybe even pulling some inspiration
from monster hunter world and walking to
the front gates to enter like a free
roam session of the entire world
where there could be any number of world
events to take place in or places to
explore that don't necessarily further
the story but would just serve to
generate drops for materials or other
such loot
and what if every champion had their own
hub world like playing as mifa meant you
had a similar setup in zoro's domain or
playing as rivali
not sure why you'd be playing as that
person but
that would result in rideau village as a
hub world daruk and urbosa would have
goron city and gerudo town as well etc
etc
maybe i'm dreaming too largely but hey
with the way that they shadow dropped
this game in the first place
anything is possible and hub worlds are
a more modern take on gaming and would
really make the experience of this game
something unforgettable finally i'd like
to see or rather
hear a fantastic soundtrack and you
might be thinking oh
that's a lame choice but excuse you
music is incredibly important to the
impact a game has
zelda games are known for their music
and the first hyrule warriors completely
knocked it out of the park with not only
upbeat remixes of classic zelda tunes
but also some straight fire original
tracks like
this one
do you have goosebumps because i have
goosebumps i cannot wait to hear a remix
for hyrule castle or mifa's theme or
maybe some original emotional music for
that last mission when zelda sacrifices
herself to save everyone 100 years in
the future
can you tell i'm hyped am i being
obvious and there you have it guys
my brief list of 5 things i'd like to
either return or be changed in hyrule
warriors age of calamity i'm sure most
of these have already been determined
since the game is being demoed later
this month
and will release in just two short
months so either way we'll see soon how
many of these became reality
in the meantime though if you agree with
this list or maybe have some other
expectations for the game let me know in
the comments below like i said i'll be
gone for a few weeks but i look forward
to going through your comments when i
get back oh and be sure to smash those
like and subscribe buttons so this video
spreads around and i can meet all sorts
of people when i get back
also huge thanks to my supporters i have
several new names to announce this time
around
say hello to executives links anthony y
melli bear merlin the witch tilda e
and doggo you guys all amaze me and i
can't thank you enough
if you watching are interested in
helping the next video come to life and
expanding the content of this channel
click that join button below this video
or visit the links in the description
below to find out how
also down there are the links to my
social media pages and i'm like super
close to 3 000 followers on twitter so
why not come on over and say hi
that's all i've got for this one so as
always you guys be good while i'm gone
okay
keep the hype real this is
mastentindabanit signing out
see you soon
[Music]
you